[Music]
two years so let's hope we get the white
pieces and we do
from thailand now let's go b3 so there's
a long history behind the move b3 you
guys have seen me play it in
my real you know real blitz games and
i've even played it over the board
this is called the nimzo larsen it's
usually called the nimzo larsen
um yeah it does sound like vivaldi and
this is the
the ultimate uh hyper modern opening
it's the og hyper modern opening because
you're saying i literally don't give a
[ __ ]
about the center i don't want to occupy
the center with pawns i want to get my
bishop
kenod so that i attack the center from a
distance
um oh my god
h5 pre-moved okay
now that's quite the idea that might be
a novelty
actually he's probably going to prime of
h4 i should play bishop takes g7
um now we're going to
you know we're going to play the classic
b3 setup
regardless of what he decides to do
and the zen behind the b3 setup is to
clamp down
on the center in a way that doesn't
obstruct the bishop
what kinds of moves control some of the
center without obstructing the bishop
well basically anything other than d4
and at some point playing d4 is fine
so e4 is okay but it's not a great move
to combine with b3
and it's a bit hard for me to explain
why that is but
it's i'll show you guys after the game
the combination of the moves e4 and b3
can be quite a bit awkward so generally
white plays e3 in these types of
structures y plays e3
uh white and e3 just works better with
b3 it's a more modest move
but it's more solid so c4 is also often
played
let's begin with a move e3 a5
okay so a5 is a bit of a more serious
move than h5
because he wants to play a4 i mean
a5 is a legitimate move in such
positions
and we need to nip this in the bud how
do we nip this in the bud
there's many good ways to knit this in
the bud the obvious move
is simply to play a4 there's nothing
wrong with that but a4
slightly weakens the b4 square what
other methods do you guys
know of taking the sting out of a4 what
other methods exist
so there's knight c3 but knight c3
blocks the bishop that this knight on b1
usually doesn't go out to c3 until later
but the other
option as lono informs us he's the
resident specialist is to play a3
a3 uh prepares to meet a4 with b4 i'm
literally sure everybody has seen this
idea before okay now
let's develop our knight he's spent
exactly one second c6
now he plays more or less normal moves
and like i said at some point
you're going to probably play d4 and d4
leads to a situation which
some of you may not fully understand
intuitively which is okay
because you might look at the move d4
and say well then why did we feed get
out the bishop
well you should think of the bishop as
an extension or the pawn is an extension
of the bishop
the the placement of the pawn on d4 is
temporary another way to think about it
is that the bishop's going to have a lot
of kinetic
or sorry bishop is going to have a lot
of potential energy at some point later
in the game
that pawn on d4 is going to either move
to d5 or it's going to trade for one of
black central pawns that's the hope
and at that point the bishop on b2 is
going to come alive so let's go d4 and
play in the center
and i think that you guys will see that
this
exact turn of events is going to happen
in addition
you can think of this as functioning as
one unit
controlling the e5 square making it very
hard for black to go e5
okay so let's think about this bishop
where should this bishop develop itself
what do you guys think and there's
really only two possibilities there's
this and then there's this
so if we go bishop c4 we walk right into
d5 or even b5 so i think the move bishop
d3 is more active
because well it controls a lot of
squares and we prepare the movie for now
black is really towing the line here
and one of the things that you have to
understand about playing offbeat
openings like one b3 is that if your
opponent plays garbage
you need to be able to essentially in
your mind transition into something more
mainstream
so even if you're a b3 player and i tell
this to london players even though you
play the london if your opponent
if your opponent screws around then you
don't need to always make the london
moves
at some point you just got to say i'm
going to press the gas pedal and i'm
going to punish him for this crap he's
not developing any of his pieces
what do we do when our opponent doesn't
develop any of his pieces like this
well we first of all we need to control
the center and we
open the center to open the center we
need to first control it with our pawns
so here it is time for us to play what
move
it's time for us to frickin press that
gas pedal down
and that means first playing e4 which is
now justified
and you know we can consider playing e5
here but
we also can complete our development i
hope those logic makes sense i would
hesitate on e5 because e5 he can meet
with knight d5
i would start by castling let's let's
play it methodically
so he wants a fishing fishing pole kind
of idea
and now i would advocate opening the
center we don't have to play h3 that
would be playing into his hands he wants
us to play h3 so that he can leave his
knight here
and tell us how awesome he is but by
playing knight g4 he's taken his eyes
off of a particular square in the center
what square am i talking about what can
we put on that square
how do we press it down it's bang on his
center
and that fd2 is too passive boom d5
blast things open just blast it open
right without even calculating i'm
trying to open the e file this pawn on
b5 is going to be weak and finally
even this guy begins to think takes
takes now this would be correct
but now b5 is lost he loses a pawn this
bishop repositions itself onto an active
square
and he goes g6 okay
we need to continue playing actively in
order not to let him breathe
it's very important we need to keep on
tightening the noose here
one good way to tighten the news i'm
looking at this bishop and i'm saying
well it's undefended
if we look around the board we look very
carefully what square can we spot with
the bishop
we can begin by playing bishop to c6 and
attacking the rook and
it sort of the bishop is now on an
outpost we don't need to worry about it
and now as lono indicates this pawn on
d6 catches my eye
so i'm logically saying okay he's
probably going to fianchetto his bishop
which means that the pawn on d6 is going
to be left without a defender
and that probably means if we can attack
it with a knight
that's going to put him in a bad bad way
so knight bd2 comes to mind
and now let's reposition the knight to
c4 attack the pawn
and also bring this a5 pawn uh
just keep an eye on it because something
amazing is going to happen if you play
as queen c7
which you probably will first of all
it goes queen to f6 okay
so now it's kind of interesting that
he's probably going to castle that part
should be clear to everybody
and if he castles remember that his rook
is it will then be gone from h8
so what will become possible if he
castles like what particular technique
what thing no longer is a trick that he
can apply
the fishing pole line so we can begin by
playing h3 and saying
we're preventing him from castling it
was king f8
that's not not bad i have to say he's
he's playing
in a strange way but he's not playing
badly
now let's consider this pawn on d6 for a
second
and let's think about ways in which we
could increase our uh
you know dial in which we could turn the
dial up on that pawn
when we look carefully we say okay what
can attack this funnel it's on a dark
square
it's on a dark squirrel what can attack
it out the bishop well we need to go to
a3 so let's go a4 this pawn is also
hanging we can take it at our leisure
i'm not rushing with that
yep
okay so
there's one issue with bishop a3 which
is that he might play e4 it goes queen
f4
it's a little manga s i i don't want to
have to deal with that
so let's just go g3 and send the queen
away
now you guys might look at this and say
well doesn't this weaken our king it
does
it certainly does but it's not a big
deal his position is so passive
that we really don't need to worry too
much about our king being a little bit
weaker we have enough
uh pieces on the king side to be able to
deal with it
um in more than one way there's just you
know
you got you gotta take a little bit of a
ballsy decision sometimes
if we took the knight he would take back
and threaten made on nature that would
be the last thing we'd want to do
we could have also got bishop c1 which i
missed but
that was not necessary all right
now comes time for the crusher
let's not forget what our ultimate idea
was
our entire plan revolves around winning
this plan and he's walked right
into knight takes d6 which now comes
with devastating effect the queen is
almost trapped
it has only one square queen before and
now our secondary idea comes in i like
how
smoothly our plan comes into existence
and it and it crushes
then we go bishop a3 paving the way for
a devastating discovery against his
queen
yep so we've done everything we wanted
to do boom
goes the dynamite his queen is lost now
where should our knight go
should we take the bishop what should we
do
this was really nice yeah knight e4 is
the simplest
bye bye queen and bye buy everything
now we can we can take the knight if we
want but we don't even need to
the simplest is to push this pawn down
the middle d6 right down main street
and now we can take the fun but let's
reposition our knight on the outpost
knight g5
and the game is over okay
knight e5 okay again it doesn't matter
what you do here just
take stuff move stuff just don't give
away pieces for free
so we can take on e4 we can we can play
bishop d5
bishop b5 just take the pawn whatever
just clear the air a little bit
the power of 1v3 h4
okay g4 to keep things closed he's
probably going to sack but
stack is quite a bit less scary when
he's got no queen
yeah his position collapsed now it was
not easy the guy did not play badly he
managed to keep to to keep his position
from collapsing for a while but
when we we put enough pressure on it he
just he didn't
find it in himself to keep the defense
going
knight d5 97 let's keep attacking f4 his
knight is trapped i'm not really
commenting on this stage because
anything wins
yeah and this game is over red rover
[Music]
okay uh let's take it
here should be five we can centralize
our queen and threaten checkmate
bishop g6 is another ancillary idea that
comes to mind let's do it destroying
the protection around his king
and the game is over yeah too late for
thinking exactly
you should have thought earlier
okay i'm literally struggling to figure
out which piece to take
this is an all you can eat this is a
good golden corral right here
this is freaking golden corral just push
push
win take when crush
yep another one
wow we got another queen
white to play and checkmate in one move
just to keep you guys on your feet good
job when g8 is correct
yeah wow okay
there's a lot to unpack here now
this is called the nimzovich larsen game
uh opening
who is it named after believe it or not
nemo's division larson i mean
mind boggling it was played for the
first time
in the year 1837 by a guy named
carl mayette and he was a master i
actually know who that is
and nimzovich played it pretty
extensively in the
you know in the 1920s when he was at his
most active
but it was played a handful of times in
the in the 1800s
you know by very adventurous people
thank you inspector chief
and marozzi played it the people
people with pretty recognizable names a
guy named magnus played in 1868
some guy with the last name magnus
played it in a symbol against a strong
against a strong german master in 1868
carlson magnus kolnoski and nimzovich
played it
and with mixed results and then larson
played it a ton
in the 60s and 70s and larson nimitz
was the guy who really advocated for
this initially
because people before nimzovich were
just experimenting with this
larson was the person who really added a
lot of theory
now b3
has you know it was on the fringes
really until the 2000s when people like
jaba and
started playing this a lot and i played
this a lot you know
for now for a couple of years now
because it turns out that this is a very
good way to
a avoid a lot of the theory and b get
fresh interesting positions white's not
really aiming for an advantage
white is aiming for interesting
positions and if black is not careful
in the main lines he can definitely get
in trouble so most people
respond here with e5 that's this is the
traditional way of
responding with black some people go d5
here automatically you remember that you
can just take the pawn
i'm sure alone you've had this a million
times probably
and after e3 knight f6
there are two main moves the old main
line is bishop b5 this is still good
but recently i've been playing knight f3
a lot of people have been playing knight
f3
in classic hyper modern style sending
provoking this pawn forward and then
trying to attack it and undermine it
with moves like d3
so it's you know i like it it's a good
opening
i have a student who plays b3 it's it's
it's very much uh very much sound and
you can study it and become a specialist
okay so i should say that the on
which is e4b6 is also playable it's
definitely playable at a club player
level but it's much more dubious than b3
e4b6 you can get crushed if you're not
very precise with black
and white is better objectively b3 white
is not worse this is equal
this is equal if black knows what he's
doing but black can equalize in a
million different ways
okay um
so yeah so b4 e5 and i just want to tell
you guys
why e4 is not the best way to play and
when i look at this
it's like if you're a pianist and you're
hitting hearing somebody play the wrong
notes
in a buck right you just it look great
on your ears it grates on your eyes
thank you i am crumb so it's just the
fact that you've encountered the bishop
and played e4 it's hard to defend this
pawn
i don't know if it makes sense what i'm
saying because
normally you can play knight c3 but now
if you play knight c3 this bishop
stares at the knight that's awkward and
if you play d3
you know all these holes on on the dark
squares and this bishop doesn't have a
good square
so it's just not the way that it's not
in the spirit of the light it's
contradictory
you don't play b3 to occupy most of the
center you do it to attack the center
with pieces if that makes sense
all right so b3
d6 is fine i mean there's nothing wrong
with that move provided that he
accompanies it with e5 that's a
legitimate way to play
um but h5 is obviously completely
unhinged
and funny thing is the move a5 in this
position
is a legitimate line people have played
it grandmasters i've faced it myself
in a rapid and over the board rapid game
and the idea is to undermine the you
know the pawn chain with a4
but i think that white is probably
slightly better here
and the best move against a5 is actually
c4
c4 is not an easy move to play if you
don't
if you haven't analyzed this the point
against a4
is not to take it that ruins your pawn
structure but to go b4
to go b4 and then a3 and then this pawn
is going to end up being a big weakness
so just as a little theoretical side
note so
bishop b2 h5 e3 a5 we decided to play it
more simply with a3
but yes in in over the board game i play
c4 here
just so you guys know okay so a3
and again the idea against a4 is to go
before now who can explain to me
why the move bishop b5 check doesn't win
a pawn
not bishop d7 although bishop d7 is
possible but the move is c6 just
remember
this little trap remember this little
trap if you encounter your bishop
this bishop doesn't have a passageway
back to b3
so that's a good thing to remember
bishop b5 c6 is fine
now you might look at this and say wait
a second what if i take the pawn first
and the point here is black will not do
this and blunder his exchange
but the fact is these pawns are horrible
black doesn't even have to
win the pawn back it's just that you
you're saddled with these weaknesses the
rest of the game and it's well worth
a pawn that black's probably going to
win back anyway so anyways knight f6
knight f3
c6 now we occupy the center with d4
knight b to d7 bishop comes out actively
to d3
and the move b5 is what with the straw
that broke the camel's back
if i was black here i would go g6 or e6
and
just rush to develop my pieces now we
just say let's step on id4
he correctly played e6 here because if
he had just developed his bishop
who can tell me what white should do
here black is almost losing
already and this has to do with him
playing h5 which weakens the g6
square that's something which if you're
tactically sharp you would have noticed
immediately we go
e5 and after 95 what's the key move
and this is going to be absolutely
painful
just crunch crunching through his
position e6
this is me that's the consequences of
playing
h5 and if he goes knight f6 well we can
take and
boom boom boom everything comes in with
devastating effect
so so that's why you don't play moves
like h5 now he played e6 which is good
it slows down the progress of the spine
so we decided to take a more
conservative approach castles
after knight g4 when a piece leaves the
center like this
it relinquishes control over the central
squares
now some of you might might struggle to
figure out why e5 doesn't do the same
thing as d5
the reason is simple black here black
can go d5 and keep the center closed but
after d5
sorry but after d5 black can't go e5
right because
white immediately takes you know attacks
coupons
um that's why there's often the piece of
advice that you should
you should essentially strike in the
most well protected square
which is very paradoxical but if your
goal is to open up the center
the more stuff you hit with your move
the better
if that makes sense another thing is
yeah
not going h3 here remember that when
your opponent plays like this
it's obvious what he's aiming for he
wants you to play h3 and take the knight
so we're not playing his game
we're saving a tempo on the move h3
because we won't be able to take the
knight anyway
all right so we strike in the center d5
takes takes e5 thank you for the pun
there's nothing else that he can do if
he takes
that's obviously much worse rookie one
and then then we can take the pawn and
then d5 hangs
this is horrible and please ask any
questions as i as i do this these are
this is a pretty complicated game
actually g6
i would have gone bishop e7 instead but
okay
yeah why couldn't you take that good
question sorry i should have explained
this
so the this is called the fishing pole
fishing pole trap white is not losing
here but white's going to have to give
the knight back
because if you move your knight just
myopically then queen h4 comes
mate is threatened on the h2 and h1
squares
all that remains is to try to open up a
escape passageway
but black shuts this down with g3 and
now queen h1 is unstoppable
so if you find yourself in this
situation
you're like oh [ __ ] i forgot i forgot
that this
that this fails don't panic usually the
way to deal with this is to play the
move
g3 that's a weird looking move why
because
you want to move the knight to h4 and
use it as a stop gap
if black takes then you bring your queen
out if black tries to get the queen you
know to h6 for example well your queen
is already close enough
uh to stop the worst of it you can go
bishop c1 so you have the resources and
the firepower now to prevent the
immediate checkmate
all right so just as a as a note
if you find yourself in this situation
don't be afraid to to give your knight
back
all right so d5 takes takes e5 we take
the pawn
g6 bishop c6 right bringing the bishop
onto an outpost making sure that it's
defended
hitting the rook now knight b to d2
this is the typical development move in
any b3 system
but in particular we're already eyeing
this pawn on d6 knowing that he wants to
fianchetto
thinking ahead knight c4 um
and you know this is why anticipation is
so important in chess
right you have to anticipate where your
opponent is going to develop
um you have to you know it's like when
you're driving you have to
you're making a left turn against
traffic
you start driving before the last car
passes you right so you can make it
uh in in the space you have available
and here's the same thing
you don't need to wait for your opponent
to do stuff before you begin your plans
you know he's going to develop his
bishop to g7
so let's begin already turning uh so
that we can get ic4 and in time
okay um what was the cool move
after queen c7 did i say there was a
cool move here
did i say there was a cool move here
oh yeah okay okay oh yeah yeah okay okay
so the move here
was to yeah yes sorry um the move here
was to target the a5 pawn
with with bishop c3 it's it's not as
cool as maybe i made it out to be
i just thought it was interesting that
to be honest i thought the queen was
trapped here i forgot the queen as the
square
but then we can drop the bishop back and
hit this spawn i just thought it was a
nice way
to combine the attack on all of black's
weaknesses
and that is the reason why we want the
knight to be on c4 there's two reasons
behind knight e4 being worse than knight
c4 the first
is the knight is undefended here i like
putting my pieces on squares where
they're defended by pawns you know that
but the main reason is that this knight
also brings under
attack the a5 square a5 pawn which could
be important later on
okay so knight c4 queen f6 now we go h3
now we go h3 and it's the same principle
we are preparing for the eventuality
that he will castle in which case he
will lose the knight
yeah and and then we can just move the
knight
uh ryan at this point can we take the
knight if we take to the queen we can
skewer
where which in which position oh okay
okay
now if he would have moved the night
away to h6 we would have had a very
pretty tactic
that wins the game immediately who can
spot this tactic this is not an easy
tactic
but you should sense intuitively look at
how all of our pieces are aimed in one
way or another either at his king or at
the center
something's got to give here and so you
should start looking for these
sacrifices
this is totally crushing look at how
everything is hanging
this bishop pins the knight he if he
moves the queen we take on
on g7 and everything collapses and
this is why at chess is logical at this
kind of a level because you do
everything right
you're going to have a tactic like this
so he goes king fa that's a nice move
and now we switch our attention to
increasing
the attack on the d6 pawn by
repositioning our bishop
okay queen f4 we're not intimidated we
just simply go
g3 get out of there queen e4 is the
decisive mistake you should have gone
back to f6
but at this point we already can take
the knight
at least we can consider it and this is
an advanced idea we can go knight h2
the point is our pawn on g3 prevents the
queen from coming to h4
and we have just enough time perhaps to
get our rook then to h1 but this is not
necessary if you're
if you don't feel comfortable you can
simply go bishop bishop a3 and win this
bond
you could even consider bishop c1 bishop
g5 which drafts the queen but that's a
little bit too much of a
kind of a trappy move yeah so
why did i go g3 now i didn't have to
strictly speaking
but i don't like situations where a
single minor piece
is what stands between me and checkmate
and what worries me about these
scenarios is a move hypothetically
doesn't work here
but a move such as e4 could come and all
of a sudden you're in a situation
where you have to do all this damage
control because your knight can't move
and it's attacked if that makes sense
so we can afford this kind of luxury
because our position is so
dominant here queen e4 now we take now
bishop a3 completes the cycle
queen has nowhere to go he goes to b6 we
can take the bishop and win it
it goes to c3 as he did we go back to e4
or
knight b5 would have been winning as
well crushing on
spot
any questions now a ford asks why can't
you take the knight instead of playing
g3 because
here this would be one of the worst
versions of
the fishing pole trap because we can't
move the knight due to checkmate but if
you were in the situation
who can spot an inventive defense white
does have a defense here
which i think leads to a winning
position for white but this is an only
move i mentioned this move
during the game it's not g3 g3 is okay
but g3 leads to queen takes f3 this
leads to a winning end game for white
what other move do you guys see same
kind of idea bishop to c1
not easy to see but it's better than g3
because the knight is untouchable queen
has to move away
and no matter where the queen moves you
can use the knight to block the queen's
passageway to add
into the h file same thing after queen
f5 don't go
here because that merely encourages the
queen to come to h5
but instead you go knight to g5 stopping
the queen putting the knight's body
uh over the queen's passage hr so it's
all logical you just got to be aware of
all these ideas
okay but these fishing pole
uh traps can be can be hard to deal with
which is why
unless you have to take the knight
there's no need to okay
so in the game yeah we went g3 bishop a3
and once we won the queen
everything was very straightforward
very very strange so a very rich game
lots of stuff went on and it was the
first time that we played 1v3
and this is certainly a move which you
can try out um
it's not horribly theoretical there's
some stuff to learn thank you lotto the
five
thank you so much dr alano and i'm sorry
for keeping you waiting for so long
i've been promising a b3 game forever
which is and it i don't know why i
didn't play it i
play it off in myself in in real games
as theodore mushroom priming as well
so any conceptual questions why not
castle before you open center
well we did we did castle recording
center that's it we did
we we castled first and then we opened
the center afterward
right so we followed the rules here um
oh i did have i did play a v3 game
apparently okay
now another thing i wanted to make a
more conceptual takeaway from this game
i see this problem a lot in london
players i mentioned this during the game
where let's say that you're playing the
london and some guy plays
a5 against you a lot of london players
will sort of
close their eyes and they'll go e3 and
then they'll go h3 and they'll make the
same moves against
every single system which is exactly why
i hesitate to recommend this
to people who are just learning
um now what should you do here well you
should recognize that your opponent is
violating the rules
so you need to deviate from the main
setup and immediately claim the center
this is a good chance for you
to get a dominant position in the
opening and you shouldn't be afraid even
as a london player
to play c4 and e4 and d4 you know
a lot of people over identify with i am
a london player
only play this system and they
put their head down and do this against
literally everything
you need to be able to have that uh
instinct to deviate your setup when your
opponent is doing something crappy
well the london is a good opening the
london is a good opening
well you can't play e4 i would love to
play e4 but the knight defends that
square
um the benoni's good at a high level
yeah no i just made a random like crappy
move
to show an example of that
the english is a great opening
well the main plan is just to get the
pieces out i mean
i don't know let's say you go e4 well it
depends
i mean black is already lost because you
want to go e5 and push this knight back
oh yeah you just get your pieces out
castle and then continue the central
expansion
is there a general technique to learn
the ideas of openings at my level theory
basically doesn't exist
well first of all there's no level at
which theory doesn't exist unless you're
like
you just learned the rules like you're
400 500
youtube videos are great nowadays
there's youtube videos and a lot of
different stuff thank you space time
cowboy i see people trying to bribe me
um there's youtube videos on a lot of
different stuff
and you know levy's got a lot of good
videos
there's just a lot of good stuff
eventually i'll have more opening videos
explaining ideas but remember that
even as a beginner you can learn a
little bit of theory you know you
shouldn't be allergic to memorization
and that's a pretty unconventional thing
to say but
you know i'm full of unconventional
[Music]
views